le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
à la réunion on recense 15 mille
personnes en situation de dépendance
avec un vieillissement de la population
qui s'accélère le département veut
trouver des solutions d'accompagnement
médico social pour les personnes en
perte d'autonomie
l'accueil de jour s'adresse aux
personnes du troisième âge présentant
une maladie d'alzheimer ou une maladie
apparentée
ce dispositif a pour but de conserver
l'autonomie en préservant un lien social
pour offrir une meilleure qualité de vie
nous avons passé une journée à l'accueil
de jour de saint-andré
[Musique]
s'entendre et vers 9 heures du matin les
premiers arrivés sont accueillis autour
d'une bonne tasse de café et on commence
déjà à préparer le repas du midi avec
bruno et panneaux bruno d'accord alors
c'est très important de couper les
légumes
ça permet de garder des réflexes quand
ils travaillent ensemble ils sont trois
ou quatre autour de la table c'est ce
qu'on appelle la stimulation des
réflexes sociaux c'est à dire flore en
même temps on bavarde et on dit ah bah
moi voilà vous allez les petits pois
photo comme ça non ça là où dix ou
appelle ça comment petit à petit pois
saint paul porté par l'association oria
pas et soutenue par le département led
de jour itinérante navigue entre trois
villes de l'est afin de se rendre au
plus près des réunionnais conseil
général à valider votre projet de leurs
voisins concernant son mari reste c'est
à dire des gros mots
de sade benoist apparu et saint-andré
ces drames ont bénéficié d'un accueil de
jour
tout ce qui permettra en même temps je
veux dire c'est enfin les vieux aussi le
sucre et à la famille parce que ces
familles ont besoin de sérénité ont
besoin de sécurité et de savoir que les
gramounes à la réunion sont en même
temps un emploi stable avec un besoin
médico sociales appropriées
alors
dépendances
rythmant la journée l'équipe encadrante
a prévu différentes activités
alors là on va faire un petit atelier
cognitif pour réactiver les sur tous les
savoirs au niveau des proverbes d
expression d expression française qui
sont encore en tête il suffit juste de
dépoussiérer un petit peu moisi prend
des petites expressions mis dans la zac
le début de l'expression est satisfait
de trouve la suite d'accords n'est pas
difficile alors pour faire la
vinaigrette qu'est-ce qu'on mènera
vinaigrette de l'huile à ben on ne peut
pas lutter l'huile jeu
andy ne faut pas bien
là je prépare et l'hydratation de
du milieu de matinée dans la mesure où
surtout après on a une activité physique
donc l'hydratation obligatoire avec un
public souffrant de la maladie
d'alzheimer ou d'une maladie apparentée
un des objectifs principaux de l'équipe
est de sortir les personnes âgées de
leur isolement
évidemment un autre but c'est la
sociabilisation c'est de ressortir c'est
de rencontrer des gens d'avoir un rendez
vous fixé à un moment donné dans la
semaine mais il n'ya pas que ça il ya
effectivement tous ces ateliers mis en
place qui semble être somme toute que de
l'occupationnel en fait en une visée
thérapeutique en soignant tout ce qu'on
appelle les troubles cognitifs qui se
trouve être oublié à la connaissance
c'est donc tout ce qui est la mémoire
tout ce qui touche les apprentissages
l'intelligence la participation le repli
sur soi en fait toutes ces choses mises
bout-à-bout qui font que les personnels
cette maladie le faire de peu à peu tout
ça 8 petit tweak ces ateliers ou par des
petites choses
on recherche au fond de chacun qui reste
est le plus longtemps possible pour que
ces gens puissent rester à domicile afin
de préserver l'autonomie des accueillis
l'esprit est sollicité mais également le
corps avec des exercices de gym douce
comme aujourd'hui en présence de
réunions en forme
on travaille tous qu'est renforcement
musculaire
dix membres inférieurs parce que le
membre inférieur est quand même un
élément important dans le camp c'est
surtout garder la forme
les faire travailler un maximum pourquoi
que les articulations se rouille entre
guillemets mais oui ça forcément
un apport thérapeutique derrière l'après
midi les activités varient selon les
envies certains préfèrent le repos
d'autres des jeux ce rendez vous
hebdomadaire rythment la vie des
accueillis comme nicole qui vient depuis
près d'un an
je vais être une fois par semaine c'est
sûr mais pointe aussi les camarades la
senza parce que je suis seul à la maison
j'essaye sont mises en face au parlement
mais donc pour moi c'est fini ce
traction et puis une animation tout ça
sap règne malgré tout à un moment donné
dans l'or dans leurs mémoires quelque
part le lieu la reconnaissance du lieu
la reconnaissance des personnes c'est
cette fixité dans le temps qu'il faut
qu'ils ont envie de venir et plus ils
ont envie de venir plus ils ont de
nouveau envie de sortir
y compris dans des sorties familiales et
de voir qu'ils peuvent de nouveau être
dans un groupe dans quelque chose c'est
que du positif
l'entrée bien passé un bon week-end
[Musique]
présent sur trois sites de l'est bras
panon saint benoît et saint andré
l'accueil de jour est un lieu
d'accompagnement médico-social
il s'adresse aux personnes âgées de plus
de 60 ans atteinte d'une maladie
d'alzheimer ou une maladie apparentée et
vivant à domicile
il propose aux personnes accueillies de
participer à des activités
thérapeutiques et ludique de conserver
l'autonomie des personnes à domicile
tout en maintenant du lien social
il permet également de soutenir les
aidants en proposant un temps de répit
dans la semaine pour plus d'informations
rendez vous sur le site du département
au www.cglpl.fr ou contacter la
résidence à steria au 02 62 94 73 20
[Musique]